now on the other hand of things that
might work versus might not work we now
are seeing almost daily installments in
this confusing bizarre kind of aimless
Republican Civil War but today we have a
new wrinkle the Republican Civil War has
mostly been anti-trump Republicans and
pro-trump Republicans fighting each
other
like I said earlier this week this is a
civil war we want to encourage it's a
good thing for this to be going on
yesterday's episode we had Dan Crenshaw
sort of a fence writer continuing to
ride the fence and tread water in the
midst of the Civil War saying well you
know
um the freedom caucus people who claim
to be very pro-trump they didn't really
vote with Trump that much but people
like Adam kinzinger who has seen as
anti-trump actually did vote for Trump
Dan Crenshaw finding a way to ride the
fence that was yesterday today there's a
new wrinkle and now it is just straight
up trumpist on trumpist Civil War today
we have trumpian lawyer Lynn wood that's
the same guy who briefly represented
Kyle Rittenhouse and that's relevant
Linwood is also the guy who was involved
in all sorts of 2020 election hijinks
that very same Linwood trumpian lawyer
attacking brutally trumpian
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green even
within the pro-trump wing of the
Republican party there is now trouble in
Paradise and we should encourage this
we should foment this Linwood is now
accusing Marjorie Taylor green
of being under the influence of not not
alcohol of the devil after Kyle
Rittenhouse claimed that Lynn wood
exploited him to make money Marjorie
Taylor green tweeted quote Lynn should
go to jail for what he did to Kyle I
also fully blame him for why Georgia
lost our Senate seats keys from Georgia
and we know him as a lifelong Democrat
not a republican he grifted off of trump
and told people not to vote on January
5th saying their vote would be stolen
Linwood has now gone to the Daily Beast
and said he's thinking about suing
Marjorie Taylor green for defamation
suing Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson for defamation and he responded
to this by saying quote I mean from a
Biblical perspective I think she's under
the influence of the devil because
people that follow Jesus Christ don't
lie
Marjorie Taylor green is a liar draw
your own conclusions Linwood also told
The Daily Beast green was one of a
number of deep State right-wing agents
working to destroy his credibility not a
surprise there so when the lunatic
extremists are fighting each other you
know that all is not well in their world
and I take two interest in this one you
already know this type of infighting can
only be good for the left it might not
help the left but it might and it
certainly doesn't help the pro-trump
right
if the left knows how to take advantage
of it but the more interesting piece is
that this is yet another data point that
what unites these people fundamentally
is not actually even support for Donald
Trump
um there was one layer which was these
are all Republicans and what unites them
as conservative values no the pro-trump
Republicans had completely different
values it's just Trump says I'm a
republican so they vote for Republicans
fine so with that with that we were done
with well maybe it's support for Trump
that actually unites them no Linwood and
Marjorie Taylor green both claim to love
Trump they both support Trump they both
say Trump is great Lynn wood claims
Trump actually won the election Marjorie
Taylor Greene claims Trump actually won
the election Lynn wood wants to take the
election back however they can
Marjorie Taylor green wants to take the
election back however they can both
believe Kyle Rittenhouse acted in
self-defense you get the point but as
soon as there's anything but complete
deference to each other personally they
go to war the Deep State this the devil
that you're subject to this even the
very trumpism that supposedly unites
them is not enough to go beyond the
personal for these folks it's a complete
and total grift and the question is
whether the left will figure out how to
take advantage of it and actually win
some elections unfortunately I remain
very skeptical that the left actually
knows what to do with this we'll talk
about what the left could do with this
on an upcoming show if you have ideas
certainly let me know I have some but
always interested in hearing from you
one of our long time sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20 off monk Pack's keto
nut and Seed bars which taste just like
your favorite sweet snacks but without
the guilt because they have only one
gram of sugar two to three net carbs and
150 calories a great snack if you're
doing keto if you're doing low carb and
if you just want a low sugar snack I
love the monk pack nut and Seed bars
great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because I like these so much I use monk
Pack's subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me ten percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as I do they will
refund you all your money I think
there's a really good chance monk pack
nut and Seed bars become your favorite
go-to snack monk pack is giving you 20
off your first order go to monkpak.com
and enter the code Pacman at checkout